[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur rt
france pour ce nouveau numéro de la
grande interview à la france se relève
peu à peu de l'épidémie de kobe de 19 et
pour faire face au virus
elle certains départements ont fait
appel à du personnel soignant venus de
l'étranger de cuba plus précisément
c'est le cas de la martinique et de la
guadeloupe
récemment le gouvernement a adopté un
article qui permet de recruter du
personnel soignant à venant de
l'étranger et c2 ce sujet dont on va
parler aujourd'hui avec notre invité et
catherine conconne sénatrice de la
martinique apparenté ps à l'origine de
cette proposition
bonjour catherine conconne merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt france
alors avant de rentrer dans le vif du
sujet je voulais vous faire réagir sur
un sujet d'actualité les modalités
d'accès à la guadeloupe et à la
martinique ont changé récemment depuis
le 18 juillet une mesure qui annonce le
retour des touristes
les départements ultramarins j'imagine
que c'est déjà une bonne nouvelle
oui c'est une bonne nouvelle pour nous
sachant plus que les mois de juillet et
août sont très prisés par le tourisme
aux communautés autrement dit comme vous
le savez la diaspora martiniquaise est
très important beaucoup de nos
compatriotes qui sont à l'étranger en
particulier en france en europe et c'est
le moment qu'ils choisissent qui
privilégie pour le moment des congés
pour venir retrouver leurs familles ont
retrouvé le pays
donc on a plusieurs plusieurs milliers
de martiniquais qui contiennent au pays
pendant les mois de juillet août en
particulier des étudiants qui rentre
pour ces deux mois de vacances donc
c'est important pour nous et puis il
faut savoir que la martinique est aussi
une terre de tourisme qui a quand même
des milliers de personnes qui vivent de
cette activité chez nous dans
l'hôtellerie la restauration dans les
loisirs et pouvoir donner des facilités
à cette clientèle
ils leur permettent de revenir dans des
conditions plus faciles à la martinique
s'était pas autant
madame la sénatrice où en est-on
aujourd'hui
de l'épidémie sur sur la martinique et
sur la guadeloupe alors aussi bien la
matinée que la guadeloupe n'ont pas été
des départements très touché par le cos
vide
simplement on a été confiné dès le
départ les mesures drastiques qui ont
été appliquées à la france l'ont été
également en simultané à la martinique à
la guadeloupe les écoles ont été fermées
toute l'activité s'est arrêtée
il fallait bien sûr comme tout le monde
des laissez-passer pour circuler le
confinement était appliquée vraiment de
manière extrêmement drastiques et même à
certains moments on a même eu droit des
couvre feu pour éviter sortir la nuit sa
vie chez nous il fait beau toute l'année
donc on est très tenté le soir de
retrouver des amis d'aller mois en cours
dans un bar quelque part donc il y avait
un couvre-feu qui vraiment mettait un
arrêt à toute cette activité qu'elle
soit des urnes ou nocturnes
donc on a eu une préservation de la
population et les racailles ont le plus
souvent été des cas importés autrement
dit des gens qui étaient rentrés qui
était revenue troisième puisqu'on est en
pleine activité en pleine saison
croisière dans la caraïbe beaucoup de
martinique et pratiquer ce loisir
ce type de vacances et puis des gens qui
rentraient par avion parce que
généralement à cette époque de haute
saison touristique c'est pas moins de
sept à huit transatlantique de plusieurs
fontaines de deux voyageurs qui arrivent
tous les jours à l'aéroport aimé césaire
donc on a eu des cas importés
mais la martinique plafonné en tout cas
un peu plus de 200 cas pas plus que ça
et puis notre chu a pu quand même à
absorber la crise
une réorganisation temps réel des
services qui a permis et de m la
réanimation tout de suite à disposition
et on a pu quand même sauvé énormément
de vie parmi nos compatriotes
madame la sénatrice vous parler bien
entendu des chu des hôpitaux
quel constat vous faites aujourd'hui
avec le recul de cette épidémie de
coronavirus est ce que c'est le même
qu'en métropole
manque de personnel manque de moyens
alors non on ne peut pas dire compte
tenu du fait qu'on n'a pas eu un gros
afflux de malades on n'a pas souffert et
on n'a pas eu à déplorer de de manque de
personnel
le personnel a été réaffecté très vite à
l'urgence covidien priorité qu'ovide
donc les gens toute l'activité des
hôpitaux a été arrêté pas d'opération
les blocs opératoires ont été libérés ce
qui fait que du personnel a pu être roi
directio né vers le service des ria real
a quelques idées très vite à l'entrée
des urgences de notre de notre hôpital
majeur l'hôpital pierre zobda-quitman il
y a eu un accueil privilégié où les gens
étaient une sorte de gare de triage on
va dire ça comme ça où les malades qui
arrivent et est tout de suite pris en
charge et ont vérifié ainsi ces
personnes avaient des problèmes liés à
l'affection revit donc on n'a pas eu de
rupture en matière de personnel ça a été
tendu
je leur rends hommage des gens qu'on
travaille énormément
par contre on a eu des problèmes de
matériel d'approvisionnement plus plus
amplifiée qu'en france puisque comme
vous le savez il fallait que ce matériel
rentrer rapidement il n'y avait plus que
deux transatlantiques semaines au lieu
des sept quotidiens donc le fret était
devenu une matière extrêmement
difficiles à mobiliser très tendu et
puis bon pour jouer la matinée qu'un
bateau il faut bien 8 à 10 jours le
temps de dédouaner le temps de défaire
les continents donc on a eu à certains
moments une grosse structure en matériel
de type blues ou blues gants masques etc
mais le pays s'est mis vous savez en une
force de résilience incroyable chez nous
face aux difficultés donc le pays s'est
mis en marche des couturières se sont
mobilisés ont fabriqué des sur blues ont
fabriqué des des masques et donc allez
on va dire que les choses
ont connu des moments difficiles une ou
deux semaines devant trois semaines
extrêmement tendue mais que la
réactivité a été à rendez-vous
alors madame la sénatrice bullet les
deux départements que sont la martinique
et la guadeloupe au moins été touchée
que la métropole vous avez quand même
fait appel à de l'aide est venue de
l'étranger a notamment avec du personnel
soignant venus de cuba racontez nous
comment sa tête s'est organisée est ce
que c'est vous qui avez fait appel au
mot personnel soignant de cuba ou alors
est-ce que c'est cuba qui a proposé son
aide pour la martinique et la guadeloupe
alors je remet les choses dans leur
contexte
il faut savoir que l'an dernier avec un
collègue guadeloupéens nous avons fait
passer une mesure qui permet d'élargir
l'appel aux médecins qui ne viennent pas
du territoire aujourd'hui on peut faire
appel à des médecins qui viennent de
l'union européenne qui peuvent aller
travailler dans n'importe quel pays de
l'union européenne y compris à la
martinique puisque nous sommes sous
régime français
mais cet appel et cette disposition est
très limité et nous sommes tout de même
en désert médical
donc l'an dernier avec un collègue en
juin de l'an dernier on a fait donc
adopté dans le cadre de la loi
modernisation santé un dispositif qui
permet de faire appel à des médecins en
union européenne
alors c'est vrai que dans notre
rétention nous ciblions énormément cuba
cuba y aller deux heures d'avion chine
ou en vol direct avec personnel médical
connue reconnue dans le monde entier et
avec il a menti nick depuis plusieurs
décennies entretient déjà des actions de
coopération
il ya le meilleur de la deuxième ville
de mantes inique qui en samo et son
successeur david zobda qui depuis près
de 30 ans organise une coopération avec
cuba font partir des martiniquais pour
se faire soigner à cuba et font venir
des des praticiens cubain qui de temps
en temps au travail dans nos hôpitaux
sur des pathologies particulières par
exemple liés au diabète liées aux
problèmes de néphrologie des problèmes
de peau de cornée en ophtalmologie
nationale je me permets de vous
la tradition est ce que c'est vous qui
avez fait appel au personnel soignant
cubains ou scénario g non j'ai voulu
remettre les choses dans le contexte
donc ce dispositif a été voté et il sera
en vigueur à partir il est en vigueur à
partir de juillet juillet nous sommes en
plein mois de juillet il en vigueur à
partir de juillet le président du
conseil exécutif de la collectivité
territoriale de montigny a voulu un peu
anticipé 7,7 cette disposition et a fait
appel aux brigades de santé cubains ces
deux choses différentes des brigades de
santé ce sont c'est une organisation
cubaine qui a été organisée depuis
plusieurs décennies et qui permet à cuba
de voler au secours de pays qui
connaissent des difficultés de santé
exemple quand il ya eu la crise et vaud
l'ain
en afrique etc donc ils sont allés en
italie sont allés un peu partout ça n'a
rien à voir avec le dispositif que nous
avons fait voter des brigades cubaine ne
sont là que pour deux ou trois mois et
en repartent dans leur pays tandis que
comme ce dispositif de juillet qui est
en cours de mise en oeuvre a en ce
moment qui fait suite à cette loi
modernisation de 2019 fera appel à des
praticiens au long cou ce sont des gens
qui viendront s'installer à la
martinique pour plusieurs mois un an
deux ans trois ans le temps de leur
contrat pour venir sur des spécialités
particulières dans lesquelles nous
souffrons de désert médical et pouvoir
travailler aux côtés des praticiens
martiniquais qui sont des gens post au
chu ça ne va concerner que le milieu
hospitalier pas le libéral catherine
conconne la france n'est pas le seul
pays à avoir demandé de l'aide
médical de la part de cuba c'est
notamment le cas de l'italie dans d'or
ou encore du qatar est ce que vous
n'avez pas l'impression de subir une
sorte d'opération de communication de la
part de cuba et qui pourrait servir
aussi qui pourrait servir de son
personnel de santé du comme d'une arme
diplomatique
non vous savez la martinique à une
proximité avec cubain qui qui qui a
toujours existé
n'oubliez pas de nous sommes des
caribéens nous sommes français à ces
dispositions politiques historiques de
notre passeport il notre nationalité
mais de coeur dans notre culture nous
sommes très proches des pays caribéens
nous avons la même histoire nous avons
subi la déportation liée à l' esclavage
nous sommes des peuples noirs du 6e ce
qu'on appelle le sixième continent
donc là menti ni à une proximité
naturelle avec cuba et qu'on ait reçu
des médecins cubains et que l'on
continue à travailler cubains ont les
fourneaux du naturel on partage avec
cuba énormément de choses
une histoire une culture la musique vous
vous allez martinique vous entendez de
la musique cubaine qui joue beaucoup de
martiniquais vos vacances à cuba
les héros de la révolution cubaine ont
été pour nos six des héros tout le monde
aime qui guevara tout le monde aime
fidel castro chez nous il y à cette
proximité de peuples opprimés qui dans
les années 60 trouve à sortir de
l'oppression coloniale se libérer d'un
certain nombre de deux joues qui pèsent
sur ces peuples là n'oubliez pas notre
histoire et pour nos cuba c'est pas une
opération de communication c'est pas une
opération de marty marketing c'est une
opération de fraternité culturel partagé
avec un peuple qui nous ressemble et
catherine gaud comme on arrive
à la moitié de notre émission je vous
propose de faire une petite pause rester
avec nous on revient dans quelques
instants à tout de suite
[Musique]
elle est de retour dans cette grande
interview vous êtes toujours sur rt
france nous sommes toujours également en
compagnie de catherine conconne
sénatrice de martinique merci catherine
conconne encore une fois d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui on parlait à l'instant
des médecins cubains des personnels
soignants venus de cuba qui était venu
vous porter main-forte 1 pendant cette
crise du coup on a virus le recours aux
médecins cubains qui intervient
justement dans un moment où des ong ont
déposé des plaintes devant la cour
pénale internationale contre cuba
justement accusés de graves violations
des droits de l'homme
les médecins ambitions sont parfois
privés de 70 à 90% de de leur salaire
ils risquent des peines de prison de 3 à
8 ans ils abandonnent leur poste entre
autres est ce que ce genre
d'informations peut être pour vous un
problème avant de faire appel à des
médecins qui viennent de cuba savez le
contrat une fois que ces dispositifs de
juillet sera formalisée dans la loi les
contrats vont être signés dans des
conditions qui respectent le droit du
travail français
donc moi je n'ai pas d'inquiétude il y a
aujourd'hui des échanges entre
diplomates cubains et français il y a
des relations qui sont noués avec les
ars de nos pays et l'état cubain et qui
va qui va permettre en tout cas
d'établir une relation sociale qui soit
juste équitable pour tous maintenant
cuba son régime
c'est vrai qu'il est décriée c'est vrai
qu'il est pointé du doigt
on parle beaucoup de droits de l'homme
qui sont bafouées et cetera
certainement mais j'ai envie de dire
aussi que cuba aussi ses bons côtés
cuba aussi un peuple qui est aujourd'hui
éduqué dans le bon sens du terme
cuba n'a pas lésiné sur les moyens les
ethnies à l'éducation à la santé
il faut également mettre sans valeur et
puis est-ce que tu bats aussi ne se
durcit fie pas à cause de la situation
internationale qui lui fait pas de
cadeau
soyons quand même clair lorsque voix
nous avons des sanctions américaines
une des sanctions américaines qui sont
prises dans l'impunité moi je comptais
déposer une question au gouvernement
mais je vais le faire à la rentrée
puisque notre session arrive à sa fin
pour demander à l'état français
kelly l'eau réaction par rapport à ce
que subit cuba aujourd'hui le veto dont
disposent les états unis à l'eau et nous
à l'onu l'eau permet de faire n'importe
quoi
le permet de faire ce qu'ils veulent et
aujourd'hui mon peuple frais en cubain
subi de plein fouet cet embargo qui
frappe cette île cette île soeur de deux
choses qui sont inacceptables qui sont
pour moi inacceptable
on veut réduire cuba m cuba à genoux
réduit au cuba de nous pour sa
nourriture pour ces médicaments est ce
que vous vous rendez compte
qu'aujourd'hui mois caribéenne je n'ai
plus la cuba ou bana qui me permettrait
d'aller à cuba travailler avec les
cubains aller en vacances à cuba
rencontrer mais mais mais mais frire
cubain parce que les états unis étaient
à dix à la compagnie nationale de loin
des avions on l'on interdisait déjà
d'acheter aujourd'hui on leur interdit
de louer pour aller à cuba je suis
obligé aujourd'hui de quitter la vente
signés dallas paris ensuite de paris de
retourner à laval
je vous laisse imaginer les eyzies et le
bocal dans lequel on affirme cuba ne
sont le fruit je pense qu'il est temps
de réagir à ces mesures qui sont à mon
avis injuste
madame la sénatrice tout à l'heure vous
avez employé un mot fort quand on a
parlé de la situation médicale en
guadeloupe et en martinique vous avez
parlé de désert médical
aujourd'hui on est obligé de faire appel
à des soignants étrangers on ne peut pas
faire venir des des soignants français
il y en a pas assez
dans beaucoup de spécialités la france
aussi de désert la france a des
problèmes aussi sur certaines
spécialités et puis venir la martinique
est aussi un choix personnel quand
quelqu'un dit à sa vie organisée à
bordeaux à toulouse et tout lui dire de
tout vendre de totalité et de partir
s'installer à la menthe hynix et c'est
une décision personnelle qui relève de
la vie de l'individu
de ses choix de vie etc nous avons
paradoxalement dé martinique elles qui
sont fournis également qu'il devienne
médecin 60% des étudiants en médecine
martiniquais ne reviennent pas à la
menthe inique
ça me permet de coucher avec vous sur
les problèmes d'attractivité de notre
territoire de plancher avec vous sur la
baisse démographique que nous subissons
c'est le cas de la guadeloupe et la
martinique
les pays ont été saignée dans les années
60 par une immigration massive organisée
par l'état dans le cadre de ce qu'on
avait appelé le but me dom l'état
français à l'époque le président de
change de gaulle et son ministre michel
debré s'était dit la seule façon de nous
qu'il n'y ait pas de d'émeutes
provoquées
quant aux difficultés que connaissent
ces pays là était de les dégonfler entre
guillemets et de faire partie de cette
jeunesse vers la france pour qu'il y ait
moins de monde la démographie est
importante la natalité également on
faisait beaucoup d'enfants l'époque il y
avait plusieurs immeubles à la menti ni
qui se sont terminées dans le sens qui
se sont terminées par des monts en 1910
hommes 59 dans les années 60 en
guadeloupe donc on a organisé une
migration massive pendant plus de vingt
ans et on a envoyé en france des
dizaines de milliers de martiniquais de
réunionnais de guadeloupéens pour
dégonfler le pays est un peu fier parti
or les gens pour travailler en france le
plus souvent sur des des postes à bas
niveau dans les hôpitaux à la poste et
c'est donc aujourd'hui nous subissons ce
revers de 7 démographique a été purgée
qui a été tenue qui a été vidée de son
sang est aujourd'hui démentie
pâte et non plus le réflexe de revenir
parce que tout cela était organisé et
l'attractivité du pays fait aussi que et
bien les jeunes aussi se demande mais si
je retourne
est ce que j'aurai de l'activité ce que
ça va fonctionner est ce que je pourrais
exercer mon métier comme il faut il ya
encore énormément de questions qui se
posent donc nous sommes dans une logique
puis deux ans de travail au sein d'une
organisation que nous avons appelé à
lévis guay qui de rendre le sourire à la
menti ni de la remettre en lumière deux
euros donner de la considération de
faire des martiniquais qui sont ailleurs
la regarder d'un autre oeil et d'avoir
envie de revenir et en particulier par
exemple dans le domaine de la médecine
madame la sénatrice est ce que c'est ce
pourquoi aussi vous avez fait cette
proposition avec votre confrère de la
guadeloupe de la guadeloupe dominique
théophile justement pour éviter cette
désertification des médecins dans les
îles
et puis et puis tout simplement faire
revenir le personnel soignant chez vous
oui faire revenir le personnel soignant
chez nous et puis se dire que bon à deux
heures d'avion on a on a des frères
caribéen qui nous ressemble
vous savez soigner quelqu'un c'est
culturel chez nous on a une manière de
s'adresser aux gens on a une stratégie t
on nous on a cette façon de parler aux
gens lorsqu'on va s'occuper d'une
personne âgée on va la tutoyer on va
l'appeler ma petite chérie on va lui
parler avec des mots qu'elle comprend on
va avoir cette chaleur que l'on retrouve
dans nos peuples
c'est culturel c'est culturel et on a
cette façon de rendre le soin qui
ressemble qui nous forme davantage et
souvent les personnes qui sont soignés
apprécie beaucoup apprécieront je suis
sûr d'avoir quelqu'un qui leur parle qui
est un cubain qui qui lui ressemble même
si la langue n'est pas la même et on se
retrouve dans nos gestes dans cette
chaleur d'être plutôt que de quelqu'un
qui vient d'europe de l'est qu'on va pas
bien comprendre qui n'a pas la même
attitude culturel chaleureuse qui
al'habitude d'habiter nos peuples
cette proposition est aussi le symbole
d'un système sanitaire qui est à bout de
souffle très certainement on ne peut pas
dire que bon alors il ya des efforts qui
sont en coin on ne peut pas dire que le
système sanitaire français soit le pire
parce qu'on voit bien que le bon la
réactivité a quand même été allons du
jour pendant cette crise qu vite et
quand on regarde ce qui se passe aux
états unis on se dit bon à la limite
valait mieux être en france pendant
cette crise que chez le géant américain
mais on arrive aussi un système à bout
de souffle
il faut permettre à la france de
s'ouvrir vers des possibles différents
permettre à des pays comme la martinique
qui sont certes la france
nous appartenons à la république on ne
le nie pas mais de dire que
culturellement
géographiquement il ya ce que césar
avait appelé la géographie cordiale qui
à côté de nous et avec des histoires que
nous partageons un peuple qui est proche
de nous faut pouvoir aussi à diriger le
regard vers sète caraïbes qui est forte
de dix plusieurs dizaines de millions
d'habitants et avec qui nous avons
certainement des choses à dire
l'histoire nous a appris à canaliser
notre regard vers la france vers
l'europe
il faut peut-être que de temps en temps
se disent mais où est-ce qu'on habite on
est où on est dans quel milieu et
pouvoir retrouver cette cordialité qui
vient à nos côtés de peuples qui sont
friands qui ont des savoir-faire a donné
qu'ils ont des avants faire à
transmettre et c'est important qu'on
sait très important donc peut-être si
cette crise a quelque chose de bon c'est
cela le regard qui change et puis cette
façon de se prendre charge qui n'est pas
classique mais qui nous ressemble alors
madame la sénatrice vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure à partir du mois de juillet la
france pourra accueillir du personnel
soignant venant de l'étranger hors union
européenne
mais je voulais vous demander dans quel
cas en cas de crise sanitaire uniquement
ou pour pour l'année non pour l'année il
faut savoir que comme je vous le disais
en début d'émission nous souffrons de
nous sommes dans un désert médical aussi
biais dans le libéral que dans
l'hospitalière il nous manque énormément
spécialité aujourd'hui pour voir un
ophtalmo la vente unique il faut compter
un an un an et demi nous avons rendez
vous il ya des gens qui sont contre et
de prendre l'avion en cas d'urgence et
de partir à paris pour se faire soigner
parce que certainement de spécialités
manque la martinique par exemple connaît
des taux de diabète important dans sa
population
eh bien vous savez le diabète entraîne
les infections des yeux d infection des
reins et cetera donc on est on a besoin
de ce personnel spécialisé qu'on n'a pas
sur la main donc aujourd'hui les rs ont
établi une liste
spécialité priorité dans lesquels on
pourra faire appel à des médecins hors
union européenne dont des cubains mais
il ya aussi des colombiens et aussi des
brésiliens qui sont dans notre
environnement nous avons été aussi
contacté par des personnes d'afrique du
nord des algériens des marocains et qui
pour venir à la matinée et s'installer
et pouvoir travailler à l'hôpital déjà
sur ses spécialités qui nous manque
lorsque vous avez à la martinique des
centaines de personnes qui sont dialysés
et que vous n'avez plus qu'un et frau
loeb pour s'occuper d'eux eh bien je
vous laisse imaginer les drames que
parfois ce genre de situation entre
elles et catherine conconne on va
arriver à la fin de cette émission
qu'est-ce que vous rock tiendrai de
cette crise sanitaire est ce que en cas
de deuxième vague on l'espère pas bien
sûr mais est ce qu en cas de deuxième
vague est la guadeloupe et la martinique
sont prêtes vient de cette crise
sanitaire je vais retenir une chose
la nature nous a parlé de manière très
durs d'un matelas nature nous a dit
attention nous partageons à terre il
faut absolument que l'on puisse trouver
le meilleur compromis
et sachez que vous l'humain la race
humaine
on est pas maître de la terre il ya des
choses qui peuvent arriver qui vont vous
contraindre à avoir ce regard différent
sur sedan dans ce monde lequel on vit il
faut qu'on reparle solidarité il faut
qu'on regarde partage des richesses il
faut qu'on voit pas écologie en étant
décomplexée et puis qu'on puisse avancer
grâce
grâce à cette crise plus rapidement des
changements d'attitude des changements
de posture et en particulier dans tout
ce qui tout ce qui touche à l'énergie à
la préservation de la planète à la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre à
notre attitude au quotidien pour lutter
contre la pollution
c'était vraiment un moment qui nous a
dit attention même les microbes ils font
partie de la terre même les virus ils
font partie de notre milieu
donc il faudra certainement apprendre à
vivre avec et surtout que loeb arrête de
se considérer comme com
celui qui domine tout qui géante ou non
la nature nous a donné le son nous
expliquer que parfois même avec nos
belles techniques et notre belle science
il ya des choses qui pouvaient nous
mettre à genoux eh bien ça nous appelle
à l'humilité ça nous appelle à la
solidarité au partage et puis à
reprendre goût à la vie d'une autre
manière d'apprécier le quotidien d'une
autre manière en sortant des consos
profit des cons ça la réussite dans
lesquels je crois que nous étions
embarqué de manière un peu folle une
leçon de la nature voilà c'est sur ces
mots qu'on va clore cette émission merci
beaucoup catherine conconne sénatrice de
la martinique d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui merci également à vous
d'avoir suivi cette émission l'émission
justement que vous pouvez déjà retrouver
sur notre site arte france point tva
très bientôt pour un nouveau numéro de
la grande interview est resté avec nous
sur rt france
[Musique]
qui